hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
i am extremely excited
because we just got a ton of apple
silicon mac leaks
that were just revealed including the
redesigned imac
totally redesigned macbook pros two new
mac pro desktops and a new
apple display all of this just broke and
i'm more excited than ever
especially for the new redesigned
macbook pros which have been rumored for
about a year now
so in this video i'm gonna go through
all of those leaks
and give my personal thoughts and
opinions on how exactly this is gonna
play out
on these new macs and when we should
expect them to get released
so let me first start with the macbook
pros before we move on
to the others late last night ming chu
quo released a report
confirming that apple is working on two
new macs
a 14 inch and 16 inch macbook pro but
here's the best part these new macbook
pros will feature a new
flat edge design similar to the current
iphones
and ipad pro getting rid of those curved
edges
that we currently have on the macbooks
now you might be asking
why would apple do this wouldn't it make
them look very thick
well i figured out two very important
reasons why
and i'll get to them in just a minute
moving on it seems like apple is
recently doing
everything they can to satisfy the
requests of
their macbook user fan base ming chi quo
says that apple is finally getting rid
of the touch bar
instead returning to physical function
keys
this is huge because i know of so many
people that have been complaining about
the touch bar
and on my own personal 2018 15-inch
macbook pro
i've actually set the touch bar to
simply display the classic function keys
because they're so much easier to use
now some might come to the conclusion
that apple could be finally packing
in a touch screen display since they're
ditching the touch bar
and while there is a chance that that
could happen
i personally disagree here's why a long
time ago
steve jobs said touchscreen macs don't
make sense
because they're ergonomically terrible
and then in 2014
craig federighi said apple has no plans
to add a touchscreen
to a mac later phil schiller said that
it makes sense for the mac to have a
precise pointer
for user input and then once again in
2016
he said that they tried it out and
absolutely came away with the belief
that it isn't the right thing to do in
2018
craig again said that touchscreen max
would be pretty fatiguing on the
arms and even joni ive said that a touch
screen on a mac
isn't particularly useful and then just
three months ago
craig federighi was heard saying apple
wasn't even remotely
considering adding a touch screen to the
mac even with the new bixer update so
with all of that coming
directly from apple i personally doubt
that we'll be seeing a touchscreen mac
for a long time even with apple finally
ditching
the touch bar which i'm glad they're
doing because the function keys are just
better and as we already know these new
macbook pros will be coming with apple's
new
mini led displays which will basically
look
almost as good as oled displays but
without all the drawbacks
now here's another bombshell from ming
there will be
no intel cpu options for these macbook
pros going forward
in fact i personally believe that every
single mac that's about to get
redesigned
will not get an intel cpu so
new design means apple silicon chip and
as most of you already know
i think the m1x chip will be going into
both the 14 inch and
16 inch macbook pro and the performance
is gonna be insane and to confirm my
speculation
on that ming chuko also said that both
of these macbook pro models
will be using the same heat pipe design
currently used by the 16-inch macbook
pro allowing for
increased computing power which
basically means that the 14-inch
is also getting the crazy powerful m1x
chip
getting even more interesting ming said
that they're also coming
with more types of ports which i wasn't
expecting at all
this shows that apple is truly starting
to listen to their customers
and if you're wondering which ports
they're gonna have
i think that apple has a wide variety of
options because they're going to
redesign
the body itself making it flat on the
bottom
and the sides the actual sides will have
more room
for larger ports so they can potentially
add
one or two regular usb a ports if they
really wanted to
but i myself personally think that these
new macbook pros
will come with four thunderbolt 4 ports
one sd card slot a headphone jack and
one usb a port just not to make it too
busy
but i guess we'll see now the absolute
bombshell leak
is the rumor that apple is finally
bringing back the max safe
charging connector and i have a really
crazy theory
about apple's future plans for maxsafe i
believe that the main reason why apple
is giving the future macbooks
a flat side design is specifically
for the magsave feature i personally
speculate that the new flat side design
will allow apple to make a brand new
magsafe connector
that looks extremely similar to the
smart connector
on the current ipad pro so i think
there's literally going to be
three flush mounted circles or squares
on the side of the macbook pro right
next to the other ports
apple will include a new mac safe
charging cable in the box
and it simply holds on magnetically
while charging
and apple could even allow data to
travel through it now you might ask
why well you may have heard that apple
is planning to make the iphone
completely portless my theory is that
apple will literally
replace the lightning port with the same
new max safe connector right on the
bottom of the iphone as well as the mac
so the future iphone will technically be
portless
using the new completely sealed magsafe
connector
and you're going to be getting a one
meter long magsafe cable
in the box and the users who do want to
use wireless charging
can buy the maxsafe wireless charging
puck for 40
on apple's website and on the macbook
side of things you'll be getting a 2
meter long magsafe cable in the box for
charging which frees up
one of the thunderbolt ports and there
you go
apple has successfully replaced
lightning
with a new standard connector without
switching to usbc
this means that apple can continue
charging licensing fees
for this new proprietary connector and
they can continue to sell
mfi accessories just like they did with
lightning
so that's my theory and if it comes true
remember this video and by the way mark
german from bloomberg
agrees with a lot of these rumors that
mingshuko said
including the mac safe part now digging
a bit deeper into the new design
i personally believe that these macbook
pros will become
thinner to help the new flat design not
look
as thick this is exactly what apple did
with the iphone 12 lineup they had to
make it thinner
because the new flat side design makes
it look
thicker now the reason apple is going to
be able to do this with the new macbook
pros
is because they're going to pack very
cool and efficient
apple silicon chips and with those chips
will come
a brand new redesigned logic board
that's going to be taking up
much less space the touch bar is going
away
so that takes up less space and the
battery can now become
thinner and more spread out amongst the
larger interior
which comes thanks to the flat design so
yes apple will most likely
make it thinner without sacrificing
battery life because of apple silicon
and on top of that because of the new
flat design
the display portion where the webcam is
currently housed
is gonna get thicker allowing for a
1080p
webcam or maybe even face id
now as far as the release date ming chu
quo believes that they'll be coming
in the third quarter of this year which
basically puts it in between
july and the end of september so i'm
gonna personally put my money
on apple announcing these macbook pros
at wwc
in june which they've done in the past
with an official launch date
the first week of july and now let's
finally get into those other leaked macs
starting with the imac there's gonna be
two imacs
also with a new redesign which will come
with a completely flat back
and flat sides basically the same that
apple is doing to the new macbook pro
now what's very interesting is that ming
believes that the chin
will finally be going away so it's going
to look essentially like the pro display
xdr
except i think that it's probably gonna
have a small apple logo on the front
these new imacs will of course come with
the new apple silicon chips
and i personally think that the smaller
23 to 24 inch model
will come with the m1x chip just like
the new macbook pros
but the larger model will come with a
better chip
potentially with up to 20 cpu cores
and i also think that this model is
going to come with a dedicated
custom apple gpu chip now in terms of
the size
i think the larger model will come with
a new display ranging anywhere from 28
to 30 inches most likely sticking to the
same 5k resolution
but it's gonna finally come with decent
hdr support
and as far as the release date i
personally don't think they're gonna
come until
after the m1x macbook pros are released
so i'm gonna bet on sometime maybe this
fall
or maybe even winter this year now apple
is also rumored to be releasing a new
lower priced external display and i
personally think it's gonna come with
the same exact
display panel that's gonna be in the new
large imac
just like they did with the previous lg
ultra fine
4k and 5k displays so there might even
be a new 23 to 24 inch display
and a new 28 to 30 inch display and now
finally
this brings us to our last major leak of
the day
and that's rumors for mark german of
apple working on
two new mac pro desktops with one of
them coming
with a new design reminiscent of the
power mac
g4 cube this leak finally gives us a
good idea on how apple will handle
giving the mac pro the apple silicon
chip the larger mac pro that we
currently have
will simply be updated with new pci
express 4.0 support on the motherboard
new intel xeon chips new amd big navi
graphics cards
and it's going to maintain the ability
to use massive amounts of ram
and other full-size pci express cards
and i believe that this will be the
very last intel mac that will ever get
released
and i think it's going to come
potentially maybe this year the end of
december
or it's gonna come alongside the apple
silicon mac pro
next year and i think that's probably
more likely
and that redesign mac pro is gonna come
with a brand new apple silicon chip
potentially packing up to a 32 or
64 core cpu on top of that i believe
that apple will be creating
custom apple gpu cards having up to 128
cores
on one card that you can put into the
new mac pro
however it will not support third-party
graphics cards
it will only support smaller pci express
cards
like audio and networking cards but not
graphics
it'll likely pack just one large fan
that cools the entire system
and i personally think it's gonna get
released in december
of 2022 with a starting price of around
three to four thousand dollars so there
you guys have it that
was the massive arsenal of mac leaks
that we just got within the past 24
hours
so if you disagree with any of my
speculations
comment down below and click the circle
above to subscribe for more videos like
this one
and definitely check out my video on the
imac redesigned right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one